One of the components that the owning component,
that is, the one that is aggregating things, and let's say in this case it's
the ViewPort, has pointers of instance variables to the other two. It owns them.
When the scroll, ScrollBar change request that is the direct event first is in,
notified, or announce to the Viewport.
It delegates a responsibility to the other components to handle it. First off,
it has to find out from the ScrolBar what the new position is. The Viewport then
determines that it needs additional content from the FileManager in order to
reestablish the invariant. It makes a request to the FileManager for
the required lines, and then uses its own method to display them.
That is, the viewing window has aggregated the responsibility for
maintaining this invariant.